[Applaus]
[Musik]
die korona virus pandemie versetzt die
welt momentan in angst und schrecken
nun da sich das stars corona virus zwei
auch in europa und amerika rasend
schnell ausbreitet könnte das gefühl der
verunsicherung oder mitmenschen nicht
größer sein die infektionsherde befinden
sich nun nicht mehr in china sondern
über die ganze welt verstreut in italien
spanien iran frankreich deutschland in
den vereinigten staaten und vielen
vielen anderen ländern
grenzen werden abgeriegelt geschäfte und
restaurants geschlossen das öffentliche
leben zum erliegen gebracht um die
übertragung des virus von mensch zu
mensch zu verhindern
viele dieser maßnahmen erscheinen schon
wie verzweiflungstaten deswegen wollen
wir euch heute erklären wie ein land das
schon sehr früh von der epidemie
betroffen war diese erfolgreich
eindämmen konnte ohne dabei zu so
drastischen maßnahmen greifen zu müssen
wie zum beispiel die chinesin und jetzt
auch viele europäische länder bitte
schaut euch dieses video unbedingt bis
zum ende an damit er seine wichtige und
grundlegende botschaft jeder mündige
bürger über diese krise hinaus
verinnerlichen sollte auch wirklich
versteht nun schauen wir uns zunächst an
die die menschen am anfang der krise
reagiert es ist dabei durchaus
bemerkenswert wie unterschiedlich die
reaktionen auf die solche in
verschiedenen ländern ausgehen
[Musik]
in westlichen ländern sprach man am
anfang als die epidemie nur auf china
beschränkt war von nichts geringerem als
einen killer virus doch auch als in
europa und den usa der ersten fälle
auftauchten spielte man den killer virus
schnell wieder als eine einfache grippe
herunter schließlich nachdem die zahl
der infektionen auch im westen in die
höhe schoss und man in italien sehen
konnte dass die menschen ernst symptome
aufweisen viel da passiert muss
realisiert werden mussten und die
krankenhäuser zu kollabieren begangen
hat er sich die meinung der politiker
erneut in corona wurde doch wieder zu
einem gefährlichen virus erklärt welches
das potenzial hätte die
gesundheitssysteme zu überlassen
[Musik]
über nacht wurde die bedrohung real und
unabwendbar das problem ist dass lange
zeit praktisch nichts unternommen wurde
wie zb in deutschland und spanien denn
auch als bekannt war dass es schon
hunderte von infizierten gibt fanden
weiterhin munter massenveranstaltungen
und sogar politische demonstrationen
statt
[Musik]
dabei hätte man aus neuseeland chinas
durchaus lernen können dort wurde auch
so lange vertuscht und verharmlost die
katastrophe nicht mehr zu leugnen war
dann machte die chinesische regierung
jedoch eine kehrtwende um 180 grad und
ergriff radikalste maßnahmen zur
eindämmung der epidemie
in erster linie wurde die gesamte
provinz hubei mit ihrer hauptstadt wo
hahn als hotspot von der außenwelt
isoliert und eine strenge quarantäne
über alle 60 millionen dort lebenden
menschen verhängt nun zu jener zeit
wurden die drakonischen maßnahmen der
chinesischen regierung von vielen
westlichen medien als übertrieben an
müsste da gaben mittelalterlich
gebrandmarkt
und welche auf was man auch immer über
die art ihrer durchsetzung ist kann man
jedoch schon jetzt sagen dass diese
maßnahme im großen und ganzen zum erfolg
nämlich der eindämmung der ausbreitung
der seuche führten zum zeitpunkt als wir
dieses video treten berichtet china kaum
noch über neue positives echo
[Musik]
rola aus china sagt die krankheitsfreie
in johann und wobei eingedämmt bbc
ja es scheint dass china es geschafft
hat das virus zu besiegen aber die frage
die sich viele stellen ist zu welchem
preis
[Applaus]
die chinesische regierung sperrte nicht
nur 60 millionen menschen unter anderem
kater straße in ihrer häuser sondern
auch den großteil des wirtschaftslebens
1 fabriken einkaufszentren banken so gut
wie alles schauen wir uns zum beispiel
den p index an
dies ist ein indikator zur messung der
wirtschaftlichen aktivität in einem land
der auf der auftragslage von zulieferern
der industrie basiert unterhalb von 50
punkten weist dieser index auf eine
rezession nun im falle der chinesischen
industrie lag der bma im februar bei
35,7 also deutlich unter 50 und damit
ihr euch eine vorstellung machen könnt
was der niedrigste stand seit bestehen
dieses indikators war hier ein vergleich
mit den schlimmsten momenten der
finanzkrise von 2008 bei den
dienstleistungen licht ist nicht besser
das gesamte wirtschaftsgefüge chinas ist
praktisch zum stillstand gekommen und
die frage die sich viele von uns stellen
ist werden westlichen regierungen auch
bereit sein so weit zu gehen passt jetzt
bitte gut auf denn wir sprechen hier von
einer gewaltigen lawinenartige krise die
sich entfalten könnte aber gibt es denn
keine andere möglichkeit mit dem corona
virus umzugehen
nun liebe zuschauer es gibt sie und wir
sind überzeugt dass er sehr überrascht
sein werden
[Musik]
die wahl der qual
kurz gesagt es gibt drei möglichkeiten
mit dem chor virus umzugehen
[Musik]
die erste beginnt damit zunächst nichts
unternehmen sich dann zögerlich zu
halbherzigen in effektiven maßnahmen zu
überwinden um dann schließlich doch ganz
hart durchgreifen zu müssen wenn es
sowieso schon viel zu spät ist dies ist
im grunde die strategie für die sich
länder wie spanien wohl aber auch
deutschland und die vereinigten staaten
entschieden haben die zweite möglichkeit
ist die jene die china gewählt hat die
menschen in ihren häusern einzusperren
um das öffentliche leben vollkommen zu
lähmen die dritte ist der versuch einen
mittelweg zwischen beiden möglichkeiten
zu finden einen mittelweg natürlich der
auch wirklich wirksam ist
wir wissen dass die wahl zwischen diesen
strategien nicht einfach fällt deswegen
wollen wir in diesem video mit euch über
ein ansprechen dass es tatsächlich
geschafft hat den dritten weg mit erfolg
einzuschlagen
[Musik]
zumindest deutet alles darauf hin dass
es wirklich großen erfolg wir sprechen
über südkorea
schaut euch mal diese tabelle
[Musik]
nachdem mehrere tage hintereinander fast
1000 neuinfektionen pro tag gemeldet
wurden ist diese zahl schnell auf knapp
über 100 gesunken und hält sich dort auf
diese weise wird die zahl der genesung
sehr bald höher sein als die der
neuinfektionen was bedeuten würde dass
der höhepunkt der epidemie das heißt die
zahl der insgesamt aktiven fälle zu
sinken
der anderen worten zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt deutet alles darauf hin dass
südkorea die korona epidemie zumindest
im eigenen land besiegen wird
bei den heute vorliegenden daten müssen
uns daher ernsthaft und dringend mit der
frage beschäftigen wie südkorea
innerhalb weniger tage so gute
ergebnisse erzielen konnte vor allem
sollten sich dringend alle
verantwortlichen politiker und
entscheider anschauen wie es geht und
daraus schnellstmöglich lernen
südkorea ist ein land das geografisch
und sozial sehr stark mit china
verbunden ist zum beispiel gibt es
täglich dutzende von flugverbindungen
mit dem ursprungsland epidemie deshalb
hat die koreanische regierung als die
von der epidemie nicht nur sofort
ausserordentliche massnahmen auf den
flughäfen eingeführt
[Musik]
die regierung richtete getrennte
flugsteige und ankunft roten für
passagiere aus china ein und verbot
sofort alle flüge nach und aus der
provinz hubei
[Musik]
darüber hinaus wurden routinemäßig
messungen der körpertemperatur
eingeführt alle betroffenen öffentlichen
räumlichkeiten wurden nun regelmäßig
desinfiziert
all das wurde bereits eingeführt als es
in südkorea noch keinen einzigen fall
von corona gab einfach nur als
präventivmaßnahme und was tat man dann
als die ersten fälle in südkorea
entdeckt wurden hört jetzt bitte gut zu
[Musik]
ein harter kampf beginnt
das allerwichtigste was ein land tun
musste war der erste corona fall
auftaucht ist sofort den ursprung der
infektion zu identifizieren den
sogenannten patienten 0 dazu muss eine
gründliche untersuchung durchgeführt
werden wo genau sich die infizierte
person zu jedem einzelnen zeitpunkt
aufhielt und mit wem sie kontakt hatte
[Musik]
auf diese weise kann es gelingen den
allerersten überträger des virus zu
identifizieren nun im falle südkoreas
trat der erste bestätigte fall in der
start in daegu auf einer stadt mit etwa
zweieinhalb millionen einwohnern im
südosten des landes
[Musik]
blitzschnell in weniger als zwei tagen
gelang es den südkoreanischen
gesundheitsbehörden den patienten 0 zu
identifizieren eine frau die einer
christlichen sekte angehört das
schlimmste vor allem war aber dass sich
die frau in der zwischenzeit in zwei
großen menschenmenge mit insgesamt
mindestens 1000 menschen aufgehalten
hatte und so soll die ausbreitung des
corona virus in daegu ihren anfang
genommen haben und mehr noch kurz darauf
entdeckte man dass dieselbe frau an der
beerdigung des bruders des sektenführers
man hier in der stadt jean todt
teilgenommen hatte und so tauchten ein
paar tage später auch gleich viele neue
fälle in dieser stadt auf zudem sind die
sektenmitglieder äußerst verschlossenen
linken häufig die zusammenarbeit mit den
behörden ab und versuchten sogar zu
vertuschen dass sie überhaupt zu dieser
sekte gehört
sie sollen also teufel aus diesen
schlamassel alle infizierten isolieren
können
während deiner meinung nach der nächste
schritt gewesen um die situation doch
noch irgendwie zu retten nun im grunde
hat die regierung die sekte mit aller
härte des gesetzes gezwungen ihr eine
vollständige liste aller mitglieder zu
übergeben es ist nämlich von
entscheidender bedeutung menschen die
möglicherweise infiziert sind so schnell
wie möglich zu isolieren und die
risikogebiete abzuriegeln es handelt
sich um einen wettlauf gegen die zeit
bei dem jede minute zählt insgesamt
wurden auf der mitgliederliste mehr als
100.000 personen erfasst der nächste
schritt bestand nun also darin diese
mehr als 100.000 mitglieder der sekte
schnellstmöglich zu testen auch wenn sie
keinerlei symptome aufwiesen
nur damit wir uns richtig verstehen in
südkorea hat man nicht nur ein paar
anlaufstellen aufgemacht in welchen sich
leute selbstständig und freiwillig
testen lassen konnten ein südkorea
startete augenblicklich mit massentests
und zwar als gäbe es kein morgen mehr
[Musik]
es wurde von heute auf morgen eine
hochleistungs infrastruktur zur
durchführung der tests aus dem boden
gestampft man konnte alles was mit
barren ressourcen auf dieses vorhaben
alle labors im land begannen von morgens
bis abends und die nacht hindurch tests
durchzuführen man scheute wahrlich nicht
auch außergewöhnliche ideen sofort
umzusetzen zum beispiel wurden überall
drive thru zentren eingerichtet in denen
man direkt in seinem eigenen auto
getestet wird und gleich wieder
weiterfahren kann südkorea setzt auf
drive bluttest auf das corona virus im
stil von fast-food-restaurants cbs news
[Musik]
falls dann innerhalb weniger stunden ein
positives ergebnis vorliegt wird der
patient sofort benachrichtigt und
isoliert um erstens die ausbreitung der
infektion zu stoppen und zweitens so
schnell wie möglich zu untersuchen
welche anderen personen angesteckt haben
kann
auf diese weise konnten die folgen der
ausbreitung schon mal minimiert werden
und jetzt wo ihr von diesem vorgehen
smit koreas wird fragt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich wieso zum teufel nicht
auch alle anderen länder in welchen die
solche später ankam als südkorea
dieses klare und stringente verfahren
einfach vor südkorea übernommen haben
wieso wurde so lange gezögert wo doch in
dieser art von fällen vorausschauendes
und möglichst schnelles handeln immer
unerlässlich ist nun wahrscheinlich
liegt es einfach daran dass im
unterschied zu den regierungen vieler
anderer länder die südkoreanische
regierung von der ersten minute an
verstanden hat dass der einzige weg den
wettlauf gegen das virus zu beginnen
darin besteht alle infizierten zu finden
bevor eine bestimmte zahl verdeckter
infektionen überschritten wird deren
exponentielle ausbreitung dann nicht
mehr zu kontrollieren ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und genau aus diesem grund hat südkorea
so viele corona virus tests pro eine
million einwohner durchgeführt wie kein
anderes land schaut euch an
[Applaus]
die märkte wahrheit ist ganz einfach
dass diese vollkommen als sinnvoll
einleuchtenden maßnahmen jetzt in vielen
ländern europas vollkommen verpennt
wurden schließlich besteht das größte
problem mit dem hi virus oft darin dass
es hochgradig ansteckend ist was dazu
führen kann dass die zahl der fälle
exponentiell ansteigt und damit erst
einzelne krankenhäuser und dann die
gesamte gesundheitsinfrastruktur
zusammenbrechen und dann meine lieben
freunde ist die kacke erst so richtig am
dampfen denn dann sterben nicht nur
viele komplizierte die bei ausreichenden
behandlungsmöglichkeiten gar nicht in
lebensgefahr gekommen wären sondern auch
viele menschen mit anderen akuten
beschwerden weil einfach keine
behandlungs personal verfügbar ist und
keine betten frei sind dringend
notwendige op es können dann nicht mehr
durchgeführt werden und auch unter
normalen umständen relativ harmlose
dinge wie einen beinbruch beim skifahren
können nicht mehr richtig behandelt
werden und führen dann mitunter zu
bleibenden folgen und das ist genau das
was gerade in italien passiert deswegen
ließen sich die südkoreaner nicht lumpen
noch weitere geniale mittel gegen die
ausbreitung des virus einzusetzen
eine weitere wichtige waffe gegen eine
solche portale entwicklung waren auch
spezielle apps die blitzschnell auf alle
mobiltelefone im land verteilt wurden
mit hilfe dieser apps ist es möglich
alle corona virus patienten zu tracken
wichtige informationen über die
abzurufen vor allem all jene orte an
denen sich diese aufhielten
so konnte jeder schnell herausfinden ob
man eventuell kontakt zu einem
infizierten gehabt hat die mobilen
corona virus apps werden in südkorea
immer beliebter cnn business
[Musik]
auf diese weise konnten koreaner
potenziellen infektionsquellen leicht
aus dem weg gehen einfach nur mit hilfe
ihres handys natürlich werfen solche
apps fragen auf was den schutz der
privatsphäre angeht ob ein derartiger
notstand solche eingriffe in
bürgerrechte und rechtfertigt oder nicht
wollen wir an dieser stelle nicht
diskutieren auf jeden fall besteht kein
zweifel daran dass südkorea bei der
eindämmung der ausbreitung und der
diagnose geschwindigkeit weltweit
konkurrenzlose rekorde aufgestellt hat
mit dem ergebnis dass die mortalität
durch das virus im internationalen
vergleich extrem niedrig bleibt nämlich
nur bei 0,6 prozent im krassen gegensatz
zu italiens schrecklichen 7 prozent
[Musik]
südkorea hat 140.000 menschen auf das
corona virus getestet das könnte
erklären warum die sterblichkeitsrate
nur 0,6 prozent beträgt weit weniger als
in china oder den usa
business insider
[Musik]
aber moment mal einige fragen sich jetzt
vielleicht sind die eben genannten dinge
wirklich alles was die südkoreaner gegen
das virus unternommen haben reichten
diese paar maßnahmen aus um die krone
epidemie in ihrem land zu bezwingen nun
nicht wirklich es gab noch viele weitere
maßnahmen und eine davon war vielleicht
auch die wichtigste könnt ihr euch
vorstellen dass das wahr ist auch es
geht in erster linie um die
verfügbarkeit von atemschutzmasken
südkorea hat auch hier rechtzeitig alles
getan um den menschen eine ausreichende
zahl von masken für mutig
angesichts des corona virus ergreift
südkorea neue maßnahmen um genügend
atemschutzmasken im land verfügbar zu
machen
[Musik]
der wert der wahrheit
und nun kommt noch eine ganz ganz
wichtige weitere maßnahme eigentlich
handelt es sich um die grundlegendste
von die grundlage jeglichen
verhältnisses zwischen den menschen der
regierung und den medien die frage
lautet wo glaubst du verlaufen die
grenzen zwischen vertuschung und
wahrheit und zwischen wahrheit und
panikmache diese frage ist zu einer
regierung angesichts einer solchen krise
nicht leicht zu beantworten denn wenn
die situation außer kontrolle zu geraten
droht müssen die regierung eine wahl
treffen entweder klipp und klar und
ungefiltert ihren bürgern die wahrheit
sagen kein blatt vor den mund nehmen
selbst auf die gefahr hin die
bevölkerung damit in panik zu versetzen
und chaos zu verursachen oder zu lügen
und die realität vor den menschen zu
verbergen um ihnen ein falsches gefühl
der sicherheit vermitteln das aber nicht
wirklich existiert und nie wirklich
existiert
[Musik]
über diese zweite option scheint man
sich zum beispiel in spanien entschied
zu haben und auch die deutsche regierung
zeigt tradition der starke tendenzen in
diese richtung wir werden dieses thema
ganz bestimmt an späteren video
nachbereiten denn transparenz und die
möglichkeit einer abrechnung mit den
verantwortlichen ist das recht jedes
bürgers in einer demokratie in südkorea
hingegen ist man das risiko eingegangen
und hat sich dafür entschieden die
ungeschminkte wahrheit zu sagen den
mündigen bürgern gegenüber transparent
zu agieren
[Musik]
die regierung hat das virus von anfang
an sehr ernst genommen vor allem da das
land vor nicht allzu langer zeit im jahr
2015 von einem anderen corona guss dem
mars corona die ruß befallen wurde
dieses corona virus ist weitaus
deutlicher als das jetzt über den
erdball stoppen des tages corona virus 2
[Musik]
es weist nämlich ein mortalität von sage
und schreibe 34 prozent auf also etwa
zehnmal mehr
[Musik]
in gewisser weise hatte südkorea
natürlich einen gewissen
erfahrungsvorsprung und aus den fehlern
in der vergangenheit bereits gelernt die
wichtigste lektion welche die
regierungsverantwortlichen soul dabei
gelernt haben war dass es in einer
solchen situation von grundlegender
bedeutung ist gegenüber der
öffentlichkeit zu 100 prozent
transparent zu sein und die menschen wie
mündige erwachsene zu behandeln ihnen
die schmerzhafte wahrheit ins gesicht zu
sagen auch wenn dies zunächst sehr
unbequem für alle beteiligten ist denn
am ende stellt sich dieses hunden ist
das richtige heraus bedenkt bitte dass
sich von den zur zeit rund 8000 fällen
ist südkorea 5800 in gegen befinden mit
anderen worten auch drei wochen nach
ausbruch der infektion sind 75 prozent
der fälle noch immer auf jene statt
isoliert die auch ganz am anfang der
hotspot war
und das ist erst recht ein gewaltiger
erfolg wenn man bedenkt dass die stadt
überhaupt nicht abgeriegelt oder unter
quarantäne gestellt werden musste
es wurden auch keine
verkehrsverbindungen abgebrochen das
leben kann für alle anderen menschen
quasi genau so weitergehen wie bisher
und wie hat es korea geschafft die fälle
auf eine einzige stadt zu konzentrieren
ohne sie militärisch abregeln zu müssen
so wie es china mit johann getan hat nun
meine lieben freunde ich verrate euch
jetzt einen wahrhaftigen grundsatz
welchen bei all seiner einfachheit
stringenz und logik die meisten
regierungspolitiker außerhalb südkoreas
wohl nicht einzugestehen in der lage
sind
nur dadurch dass die südkoreanische
regierung ihren bürgern von der
allerersten stunde an den allerfeinsten
aller weine einschränkte machte sie
ihnen den ernster gefahr und die
situation auch welches sie sich
unbedingt vorbereiten mussten auch
psychologisch bewusst denn nur wenn man
die gefahren auch wirklich kennt weiß
man wie man wirklich auf sie reagieren
muss um eine ansteckung zu verhindern
auf diese weise verließen die
südkoreaner ihre häuser nicht mehr es
sei denn es war absolut unerlässlich sie
legten ihr soziales leben auf erinnerten
ihre arbeitszeiten entschieden sich für
home office und telearbeit und erhielten
den einigen fällen sogar eine
vorübergehende freistellung von ihrem
arbeitsplatz die straßen südkoreas seine
strände seine parks und gärten alles
absolut alles leerte sich über nacht das
leben die freude die das land
normalerweise kennzeichnet schien
plötzlich auf ein viertel des normalen
maß geschrumpft zu sein aber die
menschen waren sich dessen bewusst dass
dies nur ein kleiner preis ist für die
vermeidung eines viel gefährlicheren
szenarios
daher müssen wir uns alle die frage
stellen lohnt es sich nicht für ein paar
wochen lang seine gewohnheiten
umzustellen und sich ein wenig zu hause
zu langweilen wenn man damit eine ganze
epidemie besiegen kann
du liebe zuschauer des verhaltens
südkoreas kann uns nicht nur in dieser
krise als großes vorbild dienen und zwar
sowohl auf stars eben als auch auf der
ebene der zivilgesellschaft unter
einzelnen bürger die mit einem sehr
hohen maß an rücksichtnahme gehandelt
haben denn diejenigen jungen und
gesunden menschen die glauben das
einzige was ihnen in der kroner krise
durch rücksichtsloses verhalten und
arroganten zynismus gegenüber den
risikogruppen droht wäre sich als
asoziale arschlöcher zu entpuppen ehren
gewaltig wenn das gesundheitssystem
kollabiert werden nämlich auch viele
routiniers hell wie ein gebrochenes bein
beim skifahren schnell zum unlösbaren
problem viele menschen in europa sollten
wirklich in sich gehen und sich ein
beispiel an die südkoreaner nehmen denn
schließlich ist doch die art wie sich
einzelne und eine ganze gesellschaft
gegenüber den alten und schwachen
verhält ein ziemlich guter gradmesser
für ihre tatsächliche geistige haltung
und wahrhaftig kritisches
sozialverhalten schließlich solltet ihr
die regierenden verantwortlichen und
meinungsführer in eurem land fragen
meint ihr wirklich dass wir uns ständig
vor der ungefilterten wahrheit vor
unschönen bildern schützen müssen
endlich an uns den menschen die ihr
regiert auch zu vertrauen uns als
mündige bürger zu behandeln oder glaubt
ihr etwa dass wir im vergleich mit den
südkoreanern noch immer nicht reif sind
für eine ehrliche demokratie eine
demokratie in der die uns nicht wie
unser nützliches stimmvieh ohne maß und
verstand behandelt das euch als
zuchtmeister erzieher und form und
braucht denn falls ihr sowas wirklich
glaubt daran und geht lieber wir wollen
lieber politiker und medien die sich als
partner der bürger auf gleicher
augenhöhe verstehen nicht wie
übervorsichtige eltern und reiser
kleinkinder der warum haben es so viele
regierungen überhaupt zum point of no
return kommen lassen obwohl sie sich
längst am vorbild südkoreas hätten
orientieren können nun in der
vergangenheit hat es sich für sie
einfach ausgezahlt ernste probleme zu
verschleppen auszusitzen uns die
öffentlichkeit nur scheibchenweise mit
der wahrheit zu versorgen und zwar nur
mit jener sicht der wahrheit die den
politikern genehm ist dem crawler virus
ist derartiges taktieren natürlich
vollkommen schnuppe
daher zeigt sich in dieser krise wie
zerstörerisch dieser politikstil ist zu
viele wähler haben ihnen den regierenden
durchgehen lassen und wir alle bekommen
nun die quittung dafür
denn wie sagte schon der
literaturnobelpreisträger als
die einzige art gegen die pest zu
kämpfen sind vernunft und ehrlichkeit
und liebe zuschauer was könnt ihr
persönlich tun nun kurzfristig sei keine
zynischen arschlöcher was halt nicht in
panik und hamsterkäufe und nimmt vor
allem rücksicht auf eure mitmenschen
welche von corona virus ernsthaft
bedroht sind und auch auf die vielen
fleißigen menschen die im
gesundheitswesen arbeiten und auf die
ihr eines tages auch angewiesen sein
werde rücksicht nehmen bedeutet in
diesem fall ganz konkret unternehmen
alles damit ihr euch nicht bei anderen
ansteckt oder selbst den virus
verbreitet informationen dazu über das
einschränkung von sozialkontakten bis
zum richtigen händewaschen findet ihr im
web zur genüge gut was meint ihr dazu
welche erfahrungen habt ihr in dieser
krise mit euren
regierungsverantwortlichen den medien
und euren mit menschen gemacht schreibt
uns bitte darüber im kommentarbereich
wir werden dies vielleicht in einem
video sprechen wenn euch dieses video
etwas gebracht hat halt es bitte mit
euren freunden gibt uns ein like und
vergesst nicht unserem kanal zu
abonnieren und auch das glocken symbol
klicken denn in unserem nächsten video
werden wir wieder über carola sprechen
aber aus einem ganz anderen blickwinkel
wir werden dem ursprung der solche auf
den grund gehen und genau untersuchen
wie groß das risiko einer weiteren aus
china stammenden pandemie in zukunft ist
wir sind uns nämlich ziemlich sicher
dass kuwait nicht die letzte epidemie
und auch nicht die gefährlichste war die
wir erwarten können mehr darüber also im
nächsten video und falls ihr mehr über
südkorea erfahren wollt aber auch mal
eine pause von corona braucht seht euch
doch das letzte video über dieses
wundersame land an dass wir erst vor
kurzem herausgebracht haben dort geht es
um die skurrile geschichte wieder
eigentümer von samsung über vier jahre
als lebender toter im krankenhaus
versteckt gehalten wird damit sein erbe
wegen der hohen erbschaftsteuer in
südkorea die firma nicht verkaufen muss
das klingt verrückt ist es auch klickt
einfach oben auf den link zum video
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]